- Mr. Bean is an absolute cult classic,
whether you're talking about the movie,
the sitcom, even the animation series.
Well, today I'm gonna be
taking a look at all of them
so we can have a laugh and
learn something in the process.
Are you ready?
(squeaking)
Or should I say, (grunting)?
(Mr. Bean grunting)
- Sir, it's urgent,
we have a ruptured kidney
and massive bleeding.
(sighing)
- Okay.
- Stethoscope down,
I wanna know how they
got a ruptured kidney.
Kidneys, generally just
don't self combust.
(kidney exploding)
So I need to know why
this kidney ruptured.
- At last, Dr Bean.
- Hello Dr, got a 45 year old male.
Blood type B negative,
brought in by paramedics 10 minutes ago.
- He's got a penetrating
injury to the left chest.
- All right, no, no.
No.
My man needs to scrub in before he goes
to the operating room.
There's a very strict
way how this happens.
First, you put on your surgeon's
cap, you put on your mask
then you start washing your
hands and you do a very
thorough scrub process where you disinfect
and make sure you're sterile
up until your elbows.
Once you're sterile,
you walk into the room
making sure you're not
making contact with anything.
They then have the sterile
gown for you, which you
insert your hands through quite gently.
Then they have their sterile gloves
and all this is a process
that must be followed
to a T to make sure
that you don't cross contaminate
the sterile environment.
So no, they don't just
dress you and you run
into the operating room, like, all right,
I'm gonna save the world.
(machine beeping)
(laughing)
Now I know where that meme
comes from, number one.
Number two, you don't touch your mask
when you're in the OR.
That's not part of the sterile field.
If you touch it, you
then have to disinfect,
throw everything off and
restart the whole process again.
Not sterile M&Ms.
(laughing)
What is it?
What was that?
- [Sam] I think it's a bullet.
- Oh.
Oh, don't eat it.
Oh no!
Because that is an M&M
and M&M is made of chocolate
and the body is warm.
When it fell into the body cavity,
it would automatically melt a little bit
of the sugar off and that
sugar will then remain
in the body and serve as a
breeding ground for bacteria
and sepsis for the patient
once they close them up.
So that is actually a
really, really big problem.
You should be irrigating that
with some saline water, stat.
- It's crashing on us.
- What's his pulse, 38?
That's no bueno.
That means he's crashing.
- His heart rate is dropping,
we're gonna lose him.
- The suture car behind Mr.
Bean there is quite accurate.
We do have a lot of
different types of suture
for varying utilities
depending on what kind of
procedure you're doing.
- Sorry, sir, we're losing him.
I've got to get in there now.
Dr, you can't just--
It's too dangerous!
(laughing)
(machine beeping)
(metal clinging)
Incredible.
- By removing the bullet,
you did not save the patient's life.
Imagine, someone got shot, it
tore a hole in their arteries
and their organs.
And by taking out that bullet,
you have not solved
the problem of the fact
that the patient is bleeding internally.
So no, Mr. Bean didn't
just save him by going.
- Any kind of damage
to the brain is a very
sensitive thing to observe.
So maybe we should just step outside
and give the doctor a little room to work.
- The first nurse said we
shouldn't think of it as a coma
but more like a deep sleep.
- [Nurse] Yeah, that's sort of true.
- Jennifer.
- He talks.
- Wakey-wakey, breakfast's ready.
Jennifer.
Ba!
- Still in his bloody scrubs.
- Wake up.
Wake up.
Wake up!
- Defibrillators are not
there for you to play with
or to wake patients up.
They're meant literally
to restart your heart.
And when I say restart, it doesn't mean
that if your heart is flat-lining,
these help it restart.
What it does is it
actually stops the heart
and allows it to restart on its own.
So it's almost
like interrupting the
natural rhythm of the heart.
The reason we do the defibrillation is
in certain instances, if a
patient has an irregular rhythm
to the point where it's a useless rhythm,
or it's going too fast,
we can then control it
by doing one of these
very controlled shocks,
depending on the rhythm
that we see on the monitor.
And Mr. Bean do not use a
defibrillator to wake people up.
(light tense music)
(buzzing)
(screaming)
He didn't say clear.
(light music)
What is up with that doctor's feet?
Is he a genie?
And I don't know what that
is in the foot of his bed.
If that's his EKG
my man's having a heart
attack and we need to call--
We need to call somebody.
We need to call a cardiologist.
'Cause that's not normal.
- [Nurse] Let's take your temperature.
In we go.
- He's gonna give himself a fever.
- Right, you ready?
Oh!
- This is malingering at its finest,
where he's trying to pretend he's ill
in order to get care from somebody else.
There's actually individuals where there's
Munchausen syndrome by proxy.
When you have an individual
who is keeping their family members sick
so they're reliant on them.
I'm gonna link some resources down below
just 'cause I think it's
a really interesting read.
(upbeat music)
(screaming)
(sighing)
I don't understand.
She checked his temperature.
He had a fever.
She's rushing him to x-ray.
Does you want to check
if he has a pneumonia?
Maybe you want to listen
to his lungs first.
(spooky music)
- Right.
- Oh no.
Is he gonna get an x-ray of his chest
that they're gonna see the teddy bear?
First of all, a teddy bear
wouldn't show up like that.
Unless the Teddy bear was
made out of like metal
but otherwise you wouldn't just
see an outline of the bear.
(machine beeping)
- Scalpel.
- How about putting him to sleep?
Get a little anesthesiology
action in there.
No, we don't sharpen our scalpels
like we're going cooking.
(gasping)
(screaming)
Look at the signs in the background here:
poorly, to the right.
Healthy to the left,
cured to the right,
restaurant to the right.
What is a poorly?
- Come back here!
Oh goodness me.
- Again signs, restaurant,
chapel, bar, exit,
down, dead.
First of all, what hospital has a bar?
Actually, I think a
Grey's Anatomy hospital
might have a bar.
I remember them like in the first episode,
right in between of doing a
procedure and being post-call,
they were like, let's just
go grab a drink at the bar.
And then they all come
back to the hospital
like 10 minutes later.
Where is that bar?
Maybe it's in the hospital.
(gasping)
(wheels screeching)
There's gonna be some
serious burns on his hand.
(screaming)
There's definitely an ICD-10 code.
The ICD-10 is the
International Classification
of Diseases Manual 10.
And it's gotten so specific
that if I have a patient come in
as a result of a fall, I
can't just type in fall.
I mean I can,
but it's gonna give me
all these sub definitions
of like fall on concrete, fall on curb,
fall in park, fall in gym,
fall on grass, recently mode.
I'm not even joking.
I'm gonna try and find some weird ones
to pop up on screen here.
(sirens waling)
(audience laughing)
There's a good reason why all
ambulances have a giant sign
on the back of them that say,
keep at least 50 yards back
so they could actually
open their back door
and allow the patient or help the patient,
escort the patient into the hospital.
Because a lot of times
they're on a mobile bed.
In order for that bed to come out
you can't have a car
parked directly behind it.
(audience laughing)
Why does he have a tea kettle?
Oh no, don't take her ticket.
That's so evil.
That's worse than licking
the hospital floor.
The dirtiest part of your
body are your fingers.
And everyone's touching that thing.
Here's another 90s, funny sit-com,
me reviewing medical scenes from Seinfeld.
And here's the truth about
cracking your knuckles.
So I just did it,
but click here to find
out what that truth is
and as always stay happy and healthy.
(light upbeat music)